how long ago did he give himself up two months ago
if what is the name of jon gómez this man
got to know him and his history of the
legendary he
is sure of the privileged
corrupt class their days are numbered and it
can make many people uncomfortable
the murder of the comptroller put
pressure on both of us  we
don't know what he did to fight them we
need to use their same weapons dogs
of war
armies of a single
prosecutor against war
like what is done in the life
of an hour of the night
and now I am looking for what we are looking for
what is
a second chance that is  in
this city it's a poor game we
offer you a better thing now but on
paper and you don't work for us there
is the police who have to go around
hiring guerrillas
today he begins his new life john gómez his
boss giselle reports only to her and
me  I do with you
that you dress according to one thing in
the street if there is much talk of peace but
it is created so much by a jungle very similar
to justice each time
more capable  important never forget
whose side you are on